[Música]
el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski acusó a rusia de querer repetir
el chernóbil tras el ataque que prendió
fuego a uno de los reactores de la
central nuclear más grande de europa en
la parilla un portavoz advirtió que hay
combustible nuclear dentro y joe biden
urgió a moscú a detener el bombardeo
mientras el grueso de las fuerzas de
asalto de moscú continúa atascado en su
camino a kiev el kremlin intensificó los
bombardeos mariupol esta sitio sitiada
fue atacada ajam es cercana al segundo
aeropuerto de la capital ucraniana y en
chernigov fue recuperaron 33 cuerpos
tras el impacto de misiles
más y más ucranianos llegan a la unión
europea que por primera vez en 20 años
ordenó un estatus de protección especial
para los refugiados más de un millón ya
cruzaron las fronteras eeuu también
activo un estatus de protección temporal
un cordial saludo mi nombre es ángela
gómez y aquí están las noticias de
ucrania el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski conversó por teléfono
con su homólogo job aiden sobre el
ataque a la mayor central nuclear de
europa y confirmó que la seguridad
radiactiva se mantiene de momento en las
primeras horas de este viernes hora
local las fuerzas rusas bombardearon la
planta de sap orilla en la batalla por
el control de la ciudad con el mismo
nombre sobre el río nipper el portavoz
de la central dijo que los proyectiles
cayeron directamente sobre la planta y
que habían incendiado uno de sus seis
reactores sé que aunque está actualmente
e inoperante contiene combustible
nuclear el organismo internacional de la
energía atómica advirtió del peligro que
esto significa y va a ir en pidió a
moscú que dé acceso a los trabajadores
de emergencia se les que acusó al
kremlin de querer repetir el chernóbil
hago un llamado a todos los ucranianos a
todos los europeos a todas las personas
que conocen la palabra chernóbil que
saben cuánto dolor y víctimas trajo la
explosión de la central nuclear fue una
catástrofe mundial cientos de miles de
personas lucharon con sus consecuencias
decenas de miles de personas fueron
evacuadas
rusia quiere repetir esto y ya lo está
repitiendo
vamos al análisis con césar jaramillo
integrante de la campaña internacional
para abolir las armas nucleares ong
premio nobel de paz
2017 césar gracias a usted es casualidad
que se incendiara un reactor que no está
operativo quería rusia causar realmente
una nueva catástrofe nuclear
yo quisiera pensar que no hay una
intención de rusia de causar la pero si
eso es un riesgo enteramente previsible
que se debe evitar no se puede
subestimar el riesgo no solo en esa
planta en ese incendio que se está
desarrollando hoy en tiempo real sino
que ucrania también posee algunas 15
otras plantas nucleares todas y todas se
le presentan un riesgo de una emisión
masiva de actividad de radioactividad
que nos hace recordar la tragedia de
chernóbil que también queda en ucrania y
que ahora mismo está en manos de tropas
rusas por eso le quiero preguntar cuáles
serían los efectos de golpear el
combustible nuclear
pues ahí hay combustible altamente
radioactivo que está almacenado y allí
hay varios tipos de riesgo de medición
pero el principal que se han triplicado
incluyendo por la agencia internacional
de energía atómica es que la
refrigeración
permanente que se quiere para ese
combustible nuclear se puede interrumpir
hay unos generadores de refuerzo de tipo
o diésel pero son sólo desde alcance
temporal y con los bombardeos el
suministro permanente de electricidad
puede crear unas condiciones en que se
genere fusión radioactiva que se pueda
esparcir a la
comunidad importada la geografía europea
en el peor de los casos mire y la dehesa
polilla es la mayor central nuclear de
europa si deja de funcionar cuéntenos
por favor cuáles serían las
consecuencias en materia energética
dentro y fuera de ucrania
pues si deja de funcionar hay una
dependencia bastante grande es sobre
todo sobre todo en materia energética
pero pero hay yo diría que esa
preocupación es secundaria la principal
la principal preocupación en este
momento tiene que ver con los riesgos de
bioseguridad y de los riesgos de que
haya una una fuga de materia radiactiva
y las consecuencias que esto puede
ocasionar y por otro lado una obligación
legal de por parte de las tropas rusas
de tomar todas las precauciones
necesarias para evitar que eso suceda
miren chernóbil es una historia que no
queremos repetir y quisiera preguntarle
respecto a eso cuáles son esas
consecuencias que todavía hoy estamos
viviendo después de esa tragedia
en la zona de exclusión de chernóbil se
ha vuelto en una zona que prácticamente
es inaccesible para muchas para el resto
de las personas y de los organismos ya
los niveles de actividad han han bajado
pero se registraron daños
intergeneracionales en el ecosistema en
los los animales en la fauna en las
familias en las personas que vivían en
las zonas aledañas que todavía se viven
y todavía se sienten entonces eso es
sólo un recordatorio de la gravedad del
riesgo que
reviste el ataque militar bien sea
intencional o accidental a estas plantas
nucleares en ucrania repito está sólo
una de por lo menos 15 plantas nucleares
que están en situación de vulnerabilidad
y el riesgo continúa en la medida en que
estén son solamente las fases iniciales
del conflicto y vemos como rusia se está
preparando militarmente para aumentar su
ofensiva y en esa medida va a aumentar
la vulnerabilidad de estas plantas
nucleares muchas gracias por el análisis
continuamos con más noticias
a fuerza de asaltos detenidas durante
días en una carretera al norte de kiev
rusia ha cambiado de táctica
intensificando el bombardeo de ciudades
pese a que el jueves en las
negociaciones entre kiev y moscú se
acordó un corredor humanitario la
población dejadme ubicada a unos 5
kilómetros desde el segundo aeropuerto
de kiev evalúa los daños tras una
ofensiva por aire que dejó al menos un
fallecido y un herido y al menos de 33
cuerpos fueron recuperados tras el
embate de las fuerzas rusas en la ciudad
de cherne gov
la desigualdad entre los ejércitos de
rusia y ucrania se ha puesto en
evidencia poco más de una semana después
del inicio de la invasión revisemos
ahora el desequilibrio en las fuerzas en
el informe de umar esa
el segundo ejército del mundo contra uno
que no figura ni siquiera entre los 20
primeros después de ocho días de
invasión rusa en ucrania la devastación
es ejemplo claro de esa desigualdad y
según reconoce vladimir putin el inicio
de una victoria y
queridos camaradas quiero decirles que
la operación militar especial está
marchando estrictamente de acuerdo a la
agenda de acuerdo al plan todos los
objetivos han sido exitosamente
alcanzados spears no 36 del otro lado su
par ucraniano se muestra abierto un
diálogo directo que ponga fin al horror
esto te jugosos a tna que quiere de
nosotros váyase de nuestra tierra no se
quiere ir ahora siéntese conmigo en la
mesa de negociación estoy disponible
siéntese conmigo pero no a 30 metros
como reciba macrón ya scioli ya los
otros
macroconsult en esta vida le canto entre
mi mal pero al mismo tiempo selenski
clama por ayudas que le permitan
desplegar una defensa más efectiva
dirección vendemos tras aprobar si no
pueden introducir una zona de exclusión
aérea ahora díganos cuando si no pueden
decir ahora los ucranianos cuando le
introducirán que más necesitan digan
cuanta gente te ve morir
necesitamos aviones según entiendo este
tema está siendo discutido en polonia y
eeuu ahora y ya tecos meatballs y
explosiones touch según el portal
especializado poder de fuego global el
de ucrania apareció en el puesto 22
entre los ejércitos más poderosos del
mundo mientras que el de rusia es el
segundo su presupuesto militar es menos
del 10 por ciento de los 154 mil
millones de dólares que rusia destina a
la defensa las tropas armadas un cuarto
las aeronaves militares
318 contra cuatro mil 173 de rusia los
tanques apenas una fracción y el poder
naval un ínfimo 0,5 por ciento del de su
vecino con un millón de refugiados y
buena parte del país reducido a
escombros la negociación puede ser la
única puerta que le quede a ucrania
y en una decisión sin precedentes la
unión europea aprobó por primera vez
otorgar el estatus de protección
especial para los refugiados de la
invasión rusa que según la agencia de la
onu para los refugiados acnur son más de
un millón de personas los ucranianos
podrán moverse libremente por cualquier
estado de la unión europea durante un
año y también podrán prorrogar ese
permiso especiales durante seis meses
dos veces entretanto eeuu también tomó
medidas migratorias en apoyo a los
ucranianos que están en el país al
activar el estatus de protección
temporal
recuerde que puede en directo revisar el
avance de la situación después de la
invasión rusa y ucrania lo puede hacer
en nuestro sitio web e france24 puntocom
y cada hora tenemos informativos
actualizando las noticias siga con
nosotros esto es france24
[Música]